horror has been with Cinema since the
very beginning it's Den
it's and horror is a
genre that is very adaptable to change
I've got one that can see everybody
understands fear we're all born
afraid fear is a universal thing they
all don't laugh at the same things some
uh drama doesn't work for some audiences
but boy fear does and it's a universal
genre I would submit the greatest of all
genres the most important things to know
about making a horror film is the first
is story second is story and the third
is story without that you're lost you
have no scares you have no characters
you have nothing so it's it's got to be
a fireproof story and then fashion into
an incredible script and that's where
you start that's where you finish you
can't just do a big jump scare for no
for no reason you'll get a jump but
nothing else big deal you can do that
with a black screen and a white frame
and put a shotgun on it and that'll make
you jump startle you but it's not scary
scary comes out of story all cliches
about horror movies little final girl
the final fight don't forget them it's
all about the
story the
story back in 1982 I made a movie called
the thing was based on Nolla by John W
Campbell called who goes there it was a
monster movie and and uh it was a tough
film to shoot had to go to the Stuart
British Columbia up at a glacier to
shoot the exteriors and plus the menen
hall glacier to shoot the exteriors the
second unit I love directing the blood
test
scene that was my favorite scene to
direct and trying to Jin up the uh
suspense which one of these characters
which one of our our characters is a
creature is a monster is a thing
now
Clark and Clark was human
huh which makes you a murderer Don
it Palmer
now
this is pure nonsense doesn't prove a
thing I thought you'd feel that way Gary
you were the only one that could have
got to that blood we'll do you
last Rob Bine designed and created the
monster and the idea was it could look
like anything cuz it's imitated other
life forms throughout the universe so
that just freed him up to
bring together a design with how to do
it and that was always the big thing and
my favorite monster in that
particular sequence was the head that
comes off and grows legs and eyes crawls
around I love that one it's
fun I'm going to pick that one over
on the music and the sound effects
everything it affects what you're doing
doing on the screen everything you strip
away all that and sometimes it's more
terrifying in silence but sometimes it
requires music or it begs for
music usually when we compose for a
movie you work with the characters and
the themes and the
scenes you provide what's needed to make
the movie go it's all improvised it all
comes out as we watch the image so the
images the storytelling and the images
are spark the music my way of doing it
is to get a copy of the of the cut of
the film and turn it on and start
playing Suburban screams was really
interesting for me because it was a
remote directing I'd never done this it
was shot in
Prague and my wife was there as my eyes
and ears on the set and I was sitting in
my favorite chair in my living room
directing away I loved working with my
leading actress Julie Stewart she's
fabulous we had great locations I had a
great cameraman great assistant director
and uh it just went real
smoothly but I will say to to up andc
coming filmmakers I'm a guy who grew up
in Bowling Green Kentucky if a hill like
me can make it in the movie business you
can too you have the equipment these
days that we didn't have you can make a
movie on your phone for God's sakes make
create make a movie I want to see it
show it to
me watch Suburban screams and so many
more of your favorite horror films
streaming now on peacock cut way to go
John thank you I love it
[Music]
here